IS SO BAD.
IT'S SO BAD.
>> Jason: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN RAILING AGAINST
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SINCE THE
2016 CAMPAIGN, CLAIMING THEY
WERE DISHONEST AND BIASED
AGAINST HIM.
IT TURNS OUT HE WAS RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO HIS FORMER
EXECUTIVE EDITOR, JILL ABRAMSON.
SHE SAYS THE PAPERS NEWS PAGES,
THE HOME OF ITS STREETS NEWS
COVERAGE, HAVE BECOME
"UNMISTAKABLY ANTI-TRIM."
HERE NOW IS HOWARD KURTZ,
FOX NEWS ME ANALYST AND HOST OF
MEDIA BUZZ ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
YOU WERE THE ONE THAT BROKE THE
STORY AND FOUND WHAT SHE HAD
BEEN SAYING.
THIS IS -- WE'VE HEARD THIS
BEFORE.
WE HAVE NOT REALLY SEEN IT TO
THIS DEGREE.
>> WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THE
FORMER EDITOR OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THE STORY HAS GONE ABSOLUTELY
VIRAL.
SHE'S WRITTEN A FORTHCOMING BOOK
AND SHE SAYS, THE NEWS PAGES,
NOT THE OP-ED PLAN, THESE PAGES,
RAW OPINION, HEADLINES, THIS
BRINGS THE CASH REGISTERS.
"GIVEN ITS MOSTLY LIBERAL
AUDIENCE, THERE WAS AN IMPLICIT
FINANCIAL REWARD FOR "THE TIMES"
RUNNING A BUNCH OF ANTI-TRUMP
STORIES, THEY DROVE BY TRAFFIC
NUMBERS.
MORE THAN A HALF MILLION DIGITAL
SUBSCRIPTIONS, JUST THE FIRST
FEW MONTHS OF TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Jason: THEY WERE REWARDED
WITH CIRCULATION.
AT WHAT POINT DO THEY GET OFF
THE RAILS UNDERSIDE THAT, HEY,
WE GOT TO GO OUT AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE GIVE OUR AUDIENCE WHAT
THEY WANT RATHER THAN
PLAYING IT STRAIGHT AND DELIVER
THE NEWS?
WHY ISN'T THAT THEIR MANTRA?
>> THAT SHOULD BE THE MANTRA OF
EVERY NEWS ORGANIZATION.
I THINK A LOT OF ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE "THE TIMES" ARE FINDING
THAT THERE IS A FINANCIAL AWARD,
ALMOST A BUSINESS MODEL AND
PLAYING TO AN ANTI-TRUMP
AUDIENCE.
IN THIS CASE, YES, JILL ABRAMSON
WAS FIRED FOUR YEARS AGO.
SHE WRITES ABOUT THIS IN THE
BOOK, I WRITE ABOUT IT IN THE
COLUMN.
SHE ADMITS SHE HAD FLAWS, SHE
COULD BE SELF-RIGHTEOUS, AND
SHE'S CRITICIZING HER SUCCESSOR,
THE CURRENT EXECUTIVE EDITOR WHO
WAS HER NUMBER TWO, PLAYED A
ROLE IN THE FIRING, DOES NOT
READ TO ME LIKE SOUR GRAPES.
IT READS TO ME LIKE SOMEBODY WHO
LOVES "THE NEW YORK TIMES" --
WHO, BY THE WAY, IS NOT A FAN OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SHE'S CRITICIZED HIM IN HER OWN
COLUMNS BUT SHE BELIEVES THE
PAPER THAT SHE LOVES HAS GONE
OFF THE RAILS WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Jason: IS THERE A TERM --
IS THERE A CHANGE IN THE
JOURNALISTIC STANDARDS FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE?
I WANT TO PUT UP THIS QUOTE THAT
SHE SAYS.
"THE MORE WOKE STAFF THOUGHT
THAT URGENT TIMES CALLED FOR
URGENT MEASURES.
THE DANGERS OF TRUMP'S
PRESIDENCY OBVIATED THE OLD
STANDARDS."
THEY THINK THEY ARE
SELF-RIGHTEOUS AND JUSTIFIED IN
DOING THIS BECAUSE THERE IS THE
GREATER GOOD.
>> I'VE HEARD SO MANY
JOURNALISTS SAY THIS, PUBLICLY
OR PRIVATELY, DONALD TRUMP'S
PRESIDENCY IS SO OUT OF CONTROL,
HE'S NOT FIT FOR THE JOB, HE
JUSTIFIES WHAT WE'RE DOING.
AND IF I, WE HAVE BECOME THE
OPPOSITION PARTY, WE HAVE TO
CRUSADE AGAINST HIM.
ABRAMSON IS TELLING ABOUT THE
"THE TIMES," SHE SAID AS THE
YOUNGER STAFF, THE MORE WOKE
STAFF.
THE STANDARDS OF USE FOR EVERY
OTHER PRESIDENT, THROW THEM OUT
THE WINDOW BECAUSE AS
DONALD TRUMP BY THE MORE
ANTI-TRUMP THE "THE TIMES" IS
PERCEIVED TO BECOME OF THE MORE
IT MISTRUSTED FOR BEING BIASED.
THAT IS THE COST.
YOU MAKE LOTS OF MONEY IN THE
SHORT TERM BUT IF YOU LOSE THAT
CREDIBILITY THAT YOU ARE JUST
APPLYING A WHOLE DIFFERENT SET
OF STANDARDS FOR A PRESIDENT YOU
DON'T LIKE PERSONALLY,
VISCERALLY, IDEOLOGICALLY, I I
THINK YOUR CREDIBILITY ERODES
WITH A LARGER AUDIENCE.
>> Jason: THE RELATIONSHIP SHE
HAD WITH HILLARY CLINTON,
BECAUSE IT WASN'T ALL PRO
HILLARY CLINTON,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID BREAK
THE STORY ABOUT --
>> THE PRIVATE EMAIL SERVER.
>> Jason: THAT CAUSED SOME
DISTRESSED.
SHE SEEMED, AT LEAST FROM WHAT I
READ YOUR ARTICLE, TO SAY THAT
WAS A PROBLEM FOR HER.
>> SHE SAYS THAT SHE'S NEVER
GOTTEN ALONG WITH HILLARY.
SHE SAYS HILLARY COULD BE
PARANOID.
SHE ALSO THINKS "THE TIMES"
OVERPLAYED THE HILLARY STORY.
THAT'S BEEN THE SUBJECT OF A LOT
OF DEBATE.
THE POINT IS, THAT IS NOT ME OR
YOU ARE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING
IT, THIS IS THE FORMER EDITOR OF
THE PAPER, FORMER
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTER,
PUTTING HER THOUGHTS OF THIS
BOOK, AND ESSENTIALLY SAYING
THAT THE CRITICS ARE THE WORST
CRITICS OF THE "THE TIMES" ARE
TRUE WHEN IT COMES TO THE TRUMP
COVERAGE.
I THINK JOURNALISTS OF ALL
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE TO WORRY AT
THIS POINT -- NOT THAT THERE
SHOULDN'T BE AGGRESSIVE
REPORTING, NOT THAT THERE AREN'T
GOOD REPORTERS AT "THE TIMES,"
NOT THAT SOME OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS MISSED THE MARK
BUT THE CUMULATIVE TONE AND
VOLUME AND RELENTLESS NATURE OF
THE ANTI-TRUMP FUSELAGE I THINK
IS HURTING CREDIBILITY, AND NOW
WE HAVE JILL ABRAMSON --
>> Jason: GO TO FoxNews.com,
FIND THIS ARTICLE.
IT'S A FASCINATING READ.
I THINK IT IS MORE PROBLEMATIC
THAN JUST "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
I WONDER WHERE THESE SCHOOLS OF
JOURNALISM ARE AND WHAT THEY ARE
TEACHING THESE KIDS BECAUSE I
DON'T GET THE SENSE OF, WE
WILL REPORT THE NEWS, NOT TRY TO